hi I'm Ludwig I stream sometimes and
this is the wired autofill complete
interview
bottom of the barrel these days huh you
guys have like Ryan Reynolds not too
long ago
what Ludwig what is the Ludwig subathon
oh okay good question basically it's
it's a thing that you do as a streamer
where every time you sub it increases
the amount of time you stream and I did
one that went for a month straight and I
was on camera the whole time I got the
most Subs anyone ever has and made a lot
of money that month and that was pretty
cool and I will never do that again uh
because that was way too long of my life
that's like a percentage point of my
life but it was fun it was fun while I
said what is Ludwig's net worth getting
right into it are we do people ever
answer honestly never when you're a big
streamer it's kind of like a basketball
player and you get to be signed by a
team and YouTube signed me and they gave
me Millions thank you Susan wojitski and
so it's it's Millions now which is
um cool I guess for me and I appreciate
that Susan what chair does Ludwig use
wow people care about this what chair am
I using now like something like your
brand it's pretty nice I like it I use I
use it's the fancy chair brand Herman
Miller Aeron it's like their office
chair it's like 1400 it's one of those
buy it use it for the rest of your life
items I think gaming chairs are
generally a scam based off The Branding
that they jack up the price except for
PewDiePie's if he's watching this which
case that one's very cool and not a scam
what does Ludwig play Pokemon on okay I
know why this is Googled and it's
because I use allegedly an emulator and
every time people come to my stream and
ask me I say hey I'm not going to tell
you how I'd play this illegally just
Google it but why were you googling what
does Ludwig play Pokemon on just Google
how to play Pokemon on an emulator and
you'll get you'll get there the
internet's a wild west you'll get there
what personality type is Ludwig it's
four letters I don't know the exact ones
I think I'm
e-e-n-t-p or j e n t g e n t p j I think
what to say to Ludwig you know when
people ask me for pictures for a period
I thought I would have a code code and
if they gave me the code I would I would
never say no to someone who has a
picture but I would I would really put
100 effort in and the code was wow
Ludwig you're looking awfully hot today
damn what did you do to that hair and
then you're supposed to say a sheesh at
the end only one person ever said it to
me and it was at Disneyland and he was
incredibly nervous and I was incredibly
uncomfortable so just say hi and that's
good enough that's a good start
Dusty back there all right great did
Ludwig what did I do did Ludwig beat
Elden ring I did I did a stream where I
started playing Elden ring and I didn't
end till I beat Elden ring and it took
me 102 hours which was a while twin
gargoyles were the hardest part and the
most fun part was when I never had to
Play It Again did Ludwig beat Ninja
record I did suck it Ninja sorry no but
I did I did it was the most Subs which
is kind of an arbitrary metric of
success so it doesn't super matter but I
do have it still and I'm the most sub
twitch streamer and I'm not a twitch
streamer anymore so that's that's fun
did Ludwig play Smash I did I was a
competitive Super Smash Brothers Melee
player which is different than the new
one people think because I played smash
I'm good at the new one I'm dog [ __ ] I'm
bad and so if you want to take on my
Donkey Kong and ultimate you'll probably
win so don't expect too much but for the
GameCube one I'm better than I'm better
than like a thousand people in the world
but a thousand people are better than me
so I'm like a thousand one did Ludwig
graduate college yes I went to Harvard
of the southwest Arizona State
University and I got two degrees one in
journalism and mass communications and
the other in English literature but I'll
be honest the English literature one is
kind of fraudulent I mostly sparked out
of my way through uh but I still got it
don't take it back thank you did Ludwig
retire no
no I I think you just stopped watching
I'm here I'm here still hope you're
having a good day
oh
oh when Ludwig when did Ludwig leave
twitch December 1st 2021 I think the
brief answer is that YouTube seemed to
care more about wanting me both and how
much they were offering me and how much
they were sweet talking me and the
students we talked my ear off enough
that that I switched over when did
Ludwig start streaming May 16 2017 was
the first day that I started part-time
streaming and I played um Mario Party 2
Adventure Mode it was pretty fun and I
got the world record in that video game
and now I do a lot of different things
when does Ludwig stream on YouTube
not not that frequently okay I'm kind of
bad at maintaining a schedule and
YouTube doesn't have a hub where streams
stay so it's it's a little bit irregular
but I try to stream like five days a
week about four hours each time I stream
just maybe go to the channel and and
roll the dice maybe I'll be live when is
Ludwig's merch coming out I do it in
drops so the next one will come out at
my my next event which is a chess boxing
event where I'm gonna have people chess
and then fight each other with their
fists and they all either win by
Checkmate or knocking out their opponent
and I'll release clothing then if that
excites you
is Ludwig is Ludwig part of Mr Beast you
would think because I've done like three
Mr Beast videos but no I am just his I'm
his backup I'm his sloppy seconds and
when one of their members is sick he
calls me up the day before and usually
I'm not doing jack [ __ ] so I fly on over
to North Carolina to film something with
Mr Beast but not technically part of Mr
BEAST's crew I don't think I could to be
honest it's really stressful they film
like 20 hours and I'm not that funny for
20 hours one hour maybe 20 no is Ludwig
CEO of twitch wow where did you get lost
no no it is funny that you asked that
because the CEO of twitch is kind of
hard to find but his name's Emmett sheer
but maybe no not even maybe one day no
that just that's not me I'm not that is
Ludwig a chess Grand Master I wish I
wish I was a chess Grand Master requires
a life of dedication and about like a
2600 rating and I have a 1200 rating so
a little bit far off but I did convince
the people at chess.com to give me the
title for one day so for one day I was
technically a Grand Master on chess.com
is Ludwig a good person you know what
it's all relative and also the only time
you'll see me is when I'm trying to be
my best person possible because I would
never upload me when I'm being a bad
person or at least when I think I'm
being a bad person so you would have to
make the Judgment call but end of the
day anyone you see online you'll never
truly know if you're a good person so
you know I was thinking with a grain of
salt I try my best though is Ludwig
related to Beethoven I have no relation
to Mr beef oven my parents are simply
from Europe and enjoyed his music enough
that they called me Ludwig at Birth and
then I bastardized it when I was a small
American child and called myself Ludwig
which is not technically how you
pronounce it but no no relation
light
all right oh how do
Ludwig get famous you know what getting
famous is is a lot of luck what it
requires is for you to have all the
things set up necessary for when the
luck strikes to be able to capitalize on
it I streamed for about three years and
then there's something called covid that
happened and the website that I streamed
on called twitch tripled in size and so
I also tripled in size and then the ball
kind of keeps rolling it's I'll be
honest the rich get richer and that also
applies to streaming in YouTube so
that's kind of how I got famous in a
nutshell how did Ludwig and cutie
Cinderella meet she tried to come to my
stream to make fun of me and then I
tricked her by having her date me for
four years so joke's on you nice trick
huh Ludwig how to be a streamer I think
this is just looking up a video that I
made but I did make a video on how to be
a streamer I'm gonna try to make a new
one because I think the game has changed
a bit with like Tick Tock and how that
influences live streaming you'll see it
all the time but there's a big Tick Tock
to thing which is like posting a video
and it's like I'm playing Call of Duty
right now but every time you follow this
noise plays bruh and then you go over
and they have like 5 000 viewers and
they'll promote like a more sustainable
live stream website like YouTuber twitch
so I think that's the future it seems
like Tick Tock is where the culture is
made and where you have the best chance
to thrive as someone without an audience
if you just have a good enough idea and
can make people uh watch you how
many Subs has Ludwig gained tough
question because YouTube and twitch have
confusing words but on Twitch at one
point I had 283 000 Subs which was the
most all-time and then on YouTube I'm at
like three something million but you
don't have to pay for those subs they're
free I also lost them all I have the
record for the most Subs lost ever by
anyone the biggest fall off of all time
from 283 000 to zero so it's not all
it's cracked up to be how tall is Ludwig
from twitch a lot of week from twitch
according to the government is six foot
three because every time I go to the DMV
I add one inch to my height and I've
done that three years running now before
that I put myself at six feet but you
know depends on the day I have five
eleven days like every other guy
does Ludwig does Ludwig rock climb I
quit I used to rock climb it's like the
most fun way to exercise but every
single person I know who Rock climbs
gets injured inevitably within six to 12
months of doing it and I don't want to
do that because I'm getting old and so a
shoulder injury means six months out of
commission so now I just I work out at a
boring gym with boring weights does
Ludwig have a cat I have two cats but
the cat you might be thinking of is
Coots who's a young little kitten who I
ought because my girlfriend had been
wanting it and when I say I got it I
mean she bought it but I took a lot of
the credit there's a lot we have a
tattoo I have two tattoos and maybe I
can show you can you see that I'll tell
you the story first when I hit a
thousand Subs on Twitch I promised I
would get a tattoo of anything my
viewers wanted which was stupid on
hindsight but the memory is still sweet
and my roommate did this to me prison
style stick and poke took about four
hours I almost cried and what it's
supposed to be is a sentient cereal bowl
with a smiley face and a hovering Crown
like from the A Fairly Odd Parents what
it kind of looks like is a shitty Ramen
Bowl but I still like it
and then I have another one on my thigh
that I won't show you because I pull my
pants down but it has my best friend's
name slime on it does a lot of wig speak
Spanish no shot my mother is from Spain
and is a Spanish teacher but I never
learned Spanish from her I learned
French because she also is a French
teacher so French yes Spanish no does
Ludwig like anime many would think that
I do but I only watch anime to
understand the cultural impact on the
youth who I also have a job of
entertaining and so that's why I've
watched 1020 episodes of one piece and
not because I'm a weeb because that that
that's not me I'm not a weeb
foreign
Ludwig where does Ludwig live
everyone gets his question and it's
always the same answer we I can't tell
you that I will tell you the police did
find out a couple times because they
swatted me but but outside of that we
try to keep it low-key you know what I
mean Los Angeles that's the easiest
answer where to find Ludwig now we're
getting creepy
fortnite whoa that's a mix-up what this
is like AI wrote this I don't know is
this a thing in fortnite is Beethoven in
fortnite I could believe that I played
fortnite when it like originally popped
off like 2017 and not since so I really
don't know where it's from but I hope
you find me in fortnite where does
Ludwig get his clothes almost all of my
clothes are either gifts or given to me
by sponsors and that's pretty much
everything I wear I'm not very
fashionable I tried my best today I'm
wearing my Princess Mononoke jacket
which my girlfriend got me from one of
the best movies of all time but yeah
outside of that I I'm not a good guy to
get clothing tips from I usually wear
Crocs
last one just Ludwig just Ludwig is
Ludwig vegan I went vegan for six weeks
in college because a girl I liked was
vegan and then somebody brought Raising
Canes to my house and put it in my
fridge and I don't believe in letting
leftovers go to waste so I I broke that
pretty quick I also don't think I was
the best vegan I just ate peanut butter
jelly every day but counts technically
can Ludwig sing I do have a Christmas
album you know people do say it's like
the Mariah Carey of the 2020s what I uh
singing coach told me is that I don't
have a great singing voice but I sing
pretty poorly with a lot of confidence
and so with a bit of pitch correction it
ends up sounding really good because
half of singing is blind confidence was
Ludwig a Pro Gamer depends who you ask
but I did make some money playing video
games which I think makes me at least a
somewhat Pro Gamer a semi-pro gamer I
made about sixty dollars in my career so
not bad Ludwig this is a long one
photographic memory
no no I've I think I have bad memory
no bad memory but I'm flattered that you
thought I had photographic memory I
think it's because I played one chess
game blindfolded and I did okay but
that's all I did I did okay I did not do
that well Ludwig augrin dance the Luddy
it is taking over the Internet do I have
to do it all right
here big smiles imagine you were on
Toddlers and Tiaras and then
just gotta double pump defeat hand goes
it I thought it was dumb I've been doing
it for three years but now all of a
sudden people are doing it so I'll take
it try the Luddy at home or not I don't
know
here's the thing I think most people
celebrities and I'm a very minor
celebrity are just people and they have
pretty boring lives and pretty boring
answers but hopefully they satiated your
curiosity and I that's all I want to do
[Music]